i'm not going to be doing sauce or
eating or
bears on a type rope unless you want me
to i can do all three at the same time
oh oh that's a brilliant idea
look at me no more no longer
we've been under the monkeys for too
long
we can this monkey for our fathers
for our forefathers so now that i've
spilled all over myself hello
hi i'm markiplier don't you're me
hey mark i
came all the way out here to see you
i missed you oh yeah i don't have
there's a little thing called
by bomb the second album i'm doing all
over the place let me
you sir excuse me i'm just gonna face
what is that
oh he's about to go into oh that's so
sassy it's just
pure liquid as far as he i can see
dip below the surface and then like
there's just a giant
there but maybe you can calm down a
little bit and take care of you
oh man people don't chinese oh oh yeah
the inflatable god let me blow into this
try not to myself with the knife but
it smells like a oh oh it was a
holder oh okay that makes more sense
okay so this was a
holder for this which i'm assuming is
what was the smelly smell that was
smelling smelly but the day i
watched you on long laying in bed it
actually has the same charm and style
as like your boss and your ex uh whereas
the other one were made by other people
so i woke up and i went oh i need to sh
ashley encouraged matt to use the
telescope matt saw mike and emily
i don't know
i gotta let the squirrel throw this
peanut butter off my face